[Musique]
agoma ville de l'Est de la République
démocratique du Congo les visages sont
graves la ville est de nouveau menacée
par le M23 un groupe rebelle qui a
repris les armes il y a plusieurs mois
cette résurgence réveille les
traumatismes du passé déjà 10 ans
se rappelle qu'il y a 10 ans il n'avait
fallu que quelques heures à ces rebelles
pour s'emparer de la ville il était chez
lui quand des obus sont tombés à
quelques mètres de sa maison
la bombe est tombée dans cet enclos
et la bombe est tombée sur une jeune
fille
on l'avait soulevé jusqu'à il l'Afrique
et la bombe avait détruit même la
toiture de la maison qui à l'intérieur
non loin de là Saïd conserve encore les
douloureuses traces de ces bombardements
dans sa chair dans sa main l'étui de
l'obus qu'il a blessé sur son corps les
cicatrices visibles
regardez le trou c'est ici que la bombe
est tombée j'étais juste là quand elle
est tombée c'est ce débrie qui m'a
blessé le bras les jambes tout le corps
j'ai de grosses douleurs il y a des
jours je n'arrive même plus à marcher je
ne peux plus bouger et sortir de chez
moi j'ai aussi des bourdonnements dans
les oreilles
quand j'ai vu que le M23 avant c'est
encore vers gommage j'ai eu peur j'ai eu
peur d'être à nouveau blessé ou qu'un
membre de ma famille soit blessé
depuis plusieurs mois des affrontements
sont signalés entre les forces armées
congolaises et le M23 le groupe rebelle
reproche aux autorités de ne pas avoir
respecté des engagements sur la
réinsertion de ses combattants ils
finissent par s'emparer d'une large
partie du territoire de roudouru et son
même parvenus à occuper quelques
localités de niragonco se rapprochant
ainsi de Goma
une nouvelle offensive qui a eu l'effet
d'un coup de massue pour cette
couturière lorsqu'elle a appris que les
rebelles étaient de retour à moins d'une
vingtaine de kilomètres de Goma elle a
préféré fuir sa maison
lorsque j'ai entendu à la radio que les
rebelles étaient positionnés juste là à
kibomba je suis parti de la maison avec
mes enfants nous sommes allés nous
réfugier chez mes parents à la sortie de
la ville je dors mal depuis que le M23
n'est pas loin de Goma je suis inquiète
il y a 10 ans un obus était tombé sur ma
maison et j'ai peur qu'un nouvel obus
tombe encore sur ma maison
cette nouvelle percée du M23 n'a pas
vraiment surpris les habitants comme ce
chercheur il explique que l'armée
congolaise comme les 16000 casques bleus
déployés dans le pays ont sous-estimé
les rebelles des faits en 2013 à l'issue
d'une contre-offensive de l'armée
congolaise appuyée par une brigade
spéciale d'intervention des Nations
Unies le M23 ces réfugiés en Ouganda et
au Rwanda voisin un exil qui leur a
permis aujourd'hui de se réarmer et de
revoir leur stratégie quand ils ont
occupé cette portion du territoire
ampleur de verrouga au pire des volcans
au milieu de nulle part mais au milieu
de trois frontières mais tout le monde
le voyait mais tout le monde croyait que
ce n'était pas dangereux parce qu'ils
étaient à une dizaine de kilomètres
seulement de
grandes positions de l'armée congolaise
à bounaga par exemple mais personne
n'allait les attaquer parce qu'on voit
là peut-être qu'ils vont mourir de froid
etc les autorités congolaises accusent
le Rwanda voisin d'appuyer cette
rébellion des accusations aussi portées
par les Nations Unies les États-Unis la
Belgique et la France
Kigali continue de nier tout soutien et
accuse à son tour Kinshasa de soutenir
une autre rébellion dont les membres ont
participé au génocide de 1994 ce que
dément l'armée congolaise
faisons face
pas assez format d'un vecteur
d'autrefois aujourd'hui il y a des
nations
sont derrière ce mouvement
donc dire que les fausses armées de la
République démocratique donc du Congo
sont prêtes ou pas mais écoutez on est
une armée nationale républicaine et
notre mission elle est régalienne c'est
de défendre l'intégrité du territoire
national
agoma la ville vit désormais au rythme
des patrouilles militaires les premiers
soldats de l'armée Kenya ne sont arrivés
pour prêter main-forte à l'armée
congolaise dans le cadre d'une force
régionale mais dans la ville beaucoup
critiquent cette présence militaire
étrangère se demandant pourquoi elle ne
passe toujours pas à l'offensive pour
faire reculer les rebelles du M23